I have done a lot of astrophotography
there as well so and and I observing
faint dwarf Galaxy Stars you know these
are like 45 minutes 55 minute exposure
so you actually have a lot of time so I
would run outside
and just lay on the ground under the
southern Milky Way
beautiful right up you know there and I
would just lay there like the snow angel
you know and I just stare up there and
just kind of let my thoughts sort of
pass through my brain and just like I'm
I'm one of it right we talked about this
in the beginning this is when I
personally have the feeling that I'm a
part of it I I belong here rather than
feeling kind of small yes I'm small but
there are many other small things and
lots of small things make one big hole
yeah we're part of that big hole and um
so that's looking at the inner spirals
yes Milky Way galaxy and just you know
this this dark sky with the with the
bright stars and
I have described this in my my book um
years ago
if the Milky Way Is All Bright above you
you don't need a moon or anything you
can walk in the Starlight and you will
find your way there are no trees there
for safety reasons but you wouldn't even
run into a tree right I mean you can see
you can almost see the shadow you know
from from The Starlight because it's
such a dark side and and the stars are
so bright and these are kind of moments
that that kind of change you a little
bit
and you see the unity of it all yeah and
it's just you and nature and
you know with modern civilization and
all of that we I think we often try a
little bit too hard to be removed from
from nature you know to to be
independent of it and figuring it all
out but at the end of the day we're just
a part of it and and that really helps
me to remember that that you know
well one and the same well that fills me
with hope that could I I tend to think
of us humans as in the very early days
of whatever the heck we are so that
makes me think uh thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of years
from now there will be reaching will be
whatever we become will be traveling out
there to explore more and more and more
yeah so we're what you're doing is the
early days of Exploration with the tools
we have yes the early seafarers looking
at the sky for navigation coming up with
different theories of what uh what's on
the other side that the Earth is
starting to gain an intuition that the
Earth may be round
and then we might be able to navigate
all the way around to get to the
financial benefits of getting spices
from India whatever the reason whatever
the grant funding process is all about
but ultimately actually results in a
deep understanding of the mystery that's
uh all around us and I mean it's just to
travel out there
I mean to me
the discovery of life in the solar
system
I really hope to see that in my lifetime
some kind of some kind of Life bacteria
something maybe dead because that means
there's life everywhere
and that that just the kind of stuff
that might be out there
all the different
um
all the different environmental
conditions chemically speaking that are
out there and it just seems like when
you look at Earth life finds a way
to survive to thrive in whatever
conditions and so uh
maybe that process just kind of humbles
you as a super exciting to know that
there is life out there of different
forms and of course that raises the
question of um
what is life even would tend to have a
very human-centric perspective
of uh what is a living organism and what
is intelligence and all this kind of
stuff and all the work in artificial
intelligence now is starting to
challenge our ideas of what makes human
beings special
and I think we're doing that through all
kinds of ways and I think you're working
some part doing that as well like the
unity you feel is realizing where
uh we're part of this big mechanism of
nature whatever that is that's creating
all kinds of cool stuff from The Humble
pristine Origins to uh to today